I wanted to be able to do it in one goal
I don't want to say it cut I want to
have it so the whole thing's moving in
one take a rley Scott epic is definitely
not a walk in the park it's
crazy we're talking 11 cameras and he'll
expect action in every single one of
them we want to do as much of it for
real as we can we've run a boot camp to
make sure that all the stunt guys are up
on the commands the marching
weapons really wants that regimented
military position because that's what
makes it look
good so there's a lot of skills that
have to be taught in not only infantry
but also artillery cuz we've got lots of
artillery we've got
mortars all the explosions will be real
and once the Cannons and the guns are
going on this has that rawness to it
you're in that environment it's a
surreal
feeling
[Applause]
a